[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend erst der
Antrittsbesuch in China dann der in
Südkorea und ab heute ist
Außenministerin Anna Lena baerbock beim
g7-treffen in Japan ein Dreisprung bei
dem die erste Hürde sicher die größte
und schwierigste war ja die deutsche
Außenministerin hat in China Forderungen
gestellt keine Waffen an Russland und ja
sie hat gewarnt was die taiwanfrage
anbelangt wir werden es nicht hinnehmen
wenn es zu einer militärischen
Eskalation kommt aber was wenn doch
diese Frage bleibt unbeantwortet und für
das wir muss sie übrigens auch ziemlich
hart kämpfen national wie international
Thomas Reichert
gemeinsam im Schnellzug verreisen
der Musik lauschen
in Japan machen Annalena baerbock und
ihre G7 Kollegen ganz viel gemeinsam
gegen China aber gar auf Handel und Geld
zu verzichten da geht es dann schon los
wir haben im letzten Jahr auf brutale
Art und Weise gesehen was passiert wenn
wir glauben Handel allein sei schon eine
Strategie und dieser Fehler darf uns
nicht noch mal wiederholen wieder fahren
und deswegen haben wir als Europäische
Union dieses gemeinsame China
Verständnis soweit her aber ist es mit
dem gemeinsamen Verständnis nicht schon
gar nicht bei Frankreich Präsident
Emmanuel macron der erklärte kürzlich
ein Angriff Chinas auf der wahren sei
nicht unsere Krise das glatte Gegenteil
zu Position der EU und zu bärbock doch
mal Korn bekommt Unterstützung dass wir
aber nicht gleichzeitig in ein groß
macht Konflikt zwischen den USA und
China kommen das finde ich schon eine
berechtigte Frage über die wir offen
auch diskutieren sollten und
zumindestens hier nicht ein
empörungsritual wieder Folgen wie tief
in Berlin in der Ampel der Konflikt zu
China geht zeigt sich auch daran die AFD
sieht die Sache ähnlich wie Mütze nicht
taiwan ist nicht unsere Frage und liegt
auch nicht im Interesse unseres Landes
und dort Einzelmengen seit langem
arbeiten sie im Auswärtigen Amt an einer
China Strategie
in einem vertraulichen Entwurf vom
November heißt es man stehe in einem
systemwettbewerb mit China das Land
wolle die regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung verändern zu Deutschlands
Nachteil
doch just zu bärbox pekingbesuch
lanciert der Seeheimer Kreis der
konservative Flügel der SPD ein
gegenpapier fordert es dürfe keine Anti
china-strategie geben wer also ist
schuld am Streit in Berlin
diese Differenz ist natürlich auch
gerade von der Außenministerin der
vorgerufen worden und das sind Dinge
Differenzen die natürlich auch in Peking
sehr wahrgenommen werden den kann ich in
außenpolitischen Fragen wirklich nicht
ernst nehmen
weil und der Olaf Scholz sondern es ist
Geduld mit ihm haben ist ja vielleicht
für das innerparteiliche Klima der SPD
ganz gut aber ich glaube das ist nicht
die Richtung der Ampel dass die Ampel
die G7 und der Westen sich so schwer tun
mit einer gemeinsamen China Position das
freut am Ende vor allem China das in
solchen Fällen gerne an eine seiner
alten Weisheiten erinnert der klügste
Kriege ist der der niemals kämpfen muss
wir werden eine Welt haben in der sich
die Maschinen besser zurechtfinden
werden als die Menschen weil sie nicht
auf ihre persönliche Erfahrung begrenzt
sind sondern über alle Erfahrungen
verfügen die man aufzeichnen kann dass
visionierte der Regisseur Stanley
Kubrick
emotional begrenzt schon aber sonst ist
KI also künstliche Intelligenz ja
mittlerweile tatsächlich Bestandteil
unseres Lebens geworden Suchmaschinen
Streaming-Dienst des Spam aus E-Mails
Filtern Wetterprognosen moderne
Navigationssysteme sie alle nutzen KI
und haben damit unser Leben verändert
aber auch die Arbeitswelt steht vor
großen Veränderungen einen ein- und
Ausblick gibt die Hannover Messe
Christina
und Deutschland kann hier wirklich
Geschwindigkeit aufnehmen und da ist KI
als Technologie wichtig es braucht
schlaue Lösungen für die
Herausforderungen der Zukunft so auf der
Kanzler bei der Eröffnung resiliente
Lieferketten genügend Rohstoffe das ist
die eine Sache dessen was wir brauchen
damit die große industrielle
Transformation hin zur Klimaneutralität
gelingt
der andere Teil ist dass wir vom Reden
ins doing kommen als Inselstaat vom
Klimawandel besonders bedroht setzt
Indonesien das diesjährige Partnerland
der Messe auf die Kooperation mit
Deutschland ob CO2 neutrale Produktion
oder neue Techniken für
klimafreundlichen Wasserstoff mit KI
verbindet sich die Hoffnung auf schnelle
Innovation trotzdem gibt es Vorbehalte
nur 9% der deutschen Unternehmen greifen
auf KI zurück in Messer kann ich nutzen
um ein Brötchen zu schmieren ich kann
mich damit aber auch schneiden und so
müssen wir eben lernen mit Technologien
richtig umzugehen die Chancen zu
ergreifen und die riesigen zu minimieren
die Welt der schönen neuen ki-produkte
so leicht so schnell so cool wie möglich
statt Benzin nur Luft im Bauch ganz nach
Wunsch soll Kai den Materialeinsatz
senken oder den Energieaufwand und das
alles ohne aufwendige Tests am Ende
könnte sogar der Kaffee ein Stückchen
nachhaltiger sein
ein abruptes Ende aber nicht für die KI
über die Veränderung in der Arbeitswelt
durch künstliche Intelligenz werde ich
gleich mit einem der renommiertesten
Ökonomen unseres Landes sprechen zuvor
schauen wir auf den Mittelstand denn
auch dort kann KI ihr Potenzial
entfalten zum Beispiel durch die
intelligente Nutzung und Verknüpfung von
Daten Sven Rieken nimmt uns mit an einen
Ort den wir ich würde sagen alle kennen
von dem aber wahrscheinlich die
wenigsten wissen dass auch dort mit KI
gearbeitet wird
kleine Brötchen backen Sie hier aber
auch große mit und ohne was drauf was
und wie viel in den Ofen kommt
entscheidet eine künstliche Intelligenz
seit 2009 speichert das Kassensystem der
norddeutschen Bäckerei Kette nicht nur
jeden verkauft sondern noch eine
Rahmenbedingungen dazu Wetter Feiertage
sogar Fußballspiele des HSV im
nahegelegenen Volksparkstadion was als
Statistik anfing ist heute Grundlage für
alle Vorhersagen der Bäckerei KI wir
haben letztendlich hier Daten aus den
als mehr als aus mehr als 10 Jahren und
daraus berechnet die KI ähm
Verkaufsprognosen die dann wiederum in
eine optimale Bestellung verrechnet
werden das große Ziel dahinter ist auf
jeden Fall nachhaltiger zu arbeiten und
letztendlich eine
Lebensmittelverschwendung nicht
stattfinden zu lassen eine Verkäuferin
mit viel Berufserfahrung bekäme das
vielleicht auch hin aber wie überall in
Handel und Gastronomie fehlen diese
Fachkräfte längst müssen Aushilfen und
junger Nachwuchs den Laden Schwung
halten deshalb übernimmt hier die KI die
Rolle der Erfahrung und erledigt
Bestellung und Verkaufsprognose auf der
Basis von Millionen Daten tatsächlich
ist künstliche Intelligenz eine direkter
Antwort auf den Verlust von Wissen den
wir haben wenn eine ganze Generation von
Menschen mit großer Erfahrung in die
Rente geht denn diese Erfahrung kann auf
Maschinen übertragen werden und kann
darüber auch jungen Menschen die in den
Positionen anfangen helfen diesen Job
besser zu machen in der Bäckerei backen
am Ende auch Menschen die Brötchen aber
eben auf Grundlage der KI Prognose nur
eines wird das System für die Filiale
neben dem Volksparkstadion wohl nie
vorhersagen können gewinnt der HSV
steigt also der Umsatz oder eben nicht
gestern hat der HSV verloren aber darum
soll es jetzt nicht gehen sondern ich
möchte jetzt über die Veränderungen in
der Arbeitswelt durch künstliche
Intelligenz sprechen und zwar mit Jens
südekum er ist Professor für
internationale Volkswirtschaftslehre und
er berät die Bundesregierung in Sachen
KI ein schönen guten Abend
einen schönen Abend ich grüße Sie Herr
Professor auch wenn Sie die Frage
wahrscheinlich schon tausendmal gehört
haben ist es aber doch eine die die
Menschen ja weiterhin beschäftigt wird
KI mehr Jobs überflüssig machen als neue
schaffen
die ehrliche Antwort ist wir können es
noch nicht genau sagen weil diese
Technologie eben noch relativ neu ist
ist noch nicht so weit verbreitet es
wird also noch einige Zeit dauern bis
wir genau sehen was die Auswirkungen
sind aber wenn man so ein bisschen
extrapoliert von den vergangenen
technologischen Sprüngen etwa Robotik
oder
Computerisierung dann ist es eigentlich
immer so gewesen dass ich das in
Deutschland ziemlich gut die Waage
gehalten hat also natürlich sind Jobs
weggefallen aber es sind neue Jobs
entstanden mindestens im gleichen Ausmaß
und ich gehe eigentlich nicht davon aus
dass es bei der KI grundsätzlich anders
sein wird jetzt ist es ja so klar
Berufsbilder verändern sich auch das hat
die Geschichte gezeigt aber auch nicht
jeder kann umschulen deswegen doch noch
mal nachgefragt in der Arbeitswelt wird
es dann möglicherweise wie damals auch
bei der Automatisierung beispielsweise
in der Automobilproduktion schon auch
Verlierer geben gehört das nicht zur
Wahrheit dazu zu all den Chancen über
die wir auch gleich noch sprechen
grundsätzlich ist dass das Bild was
kommen könnte wir haben einerseits
wegbrechende stellen vielleicht auch
Arbeitslosigkeit eine Zeit lang und dann
im anderen Segment des Arbeitsmarktes
händeringenden Fachkräftemangel und dann
ist es eben nicht so leicht die Menschen
von A nach B zu bringen im Arbeitsmarkt
was eben große Umschulungen bedeuten
würde was man aber gesehen hat gerade in
der deutschen Industrie als die Roboter
kam ist es gelungen dass dort wirklich
Arbeitsplätze stabil gehalten wurden und
menschen die vorher wirklich in der
manuellen Produktion beschäftigt waren
hinterher was ganz anderes gemacht haben
Wartung Marketing ganz unterschiedliche
Dinge und die Arbeitsplätze an sich
wirklich stabil geblieben sind das ist
ein gewisser Weise der Königsweg wie man
mit so neuen Technologien umgehen kann
ob das jetzt bei der KI wieder genauso
gut funktioniert das müssen wir leider
noch abwarten das heißt die Arbeitsmarkt
Effekte können sie eben jetzt hier noch
nicht genau
verifizieren weil dafür ist die KI noch
zu jung auf dem Markt aber dann lassen
Sie uns über Chancen und Möglichkeiten
in der Arbeitswelt sprechen Pflege
Roboter beispielsweise die gibt's ja
schon sie ersetzen natürlich nicht die
menschliche Pflege es ist mehr ein
Zusammenspiel von Mensch und Maschine in
welchen anderen Bereichen werden wir das
in naher Zukunft vielleicht schon
vermehrt sehen
ich glaube es geht vor allem in vielen
Bereichen wo es Routine Tätigkeiten gibt
die relativ gut und einfach
automatisiert werden können und das
können ganz unterschiedliche Berufe sein
im Bankenwesen im Versicherungswesen
etwa auch ein Journalismus vielleicht
und das Muster ist ja dann dass Berufe
die aus vielen verschiedenen Tätigkeiten
eben typischerweise zusammengesetzt sind
dass dort eben gleich mal die eher
langweiligen Routineaufgaben
automatisiert werden können etwa durch
KI und darum dafür dann eben die
Menschen sich konzentrieren können mehr
Zeit mehr Energie verwenden können auf
die Aspekte des Berufs die eben
interaktiver spontaner sind und dadurch
im Endeffekt aber in vielen Bereichen
auch einfach insgesamt ein viel besseres
Produkt dabei herauskommt kann das
klingt gut gerade natürlich auch in so
Pflegebereich beispielsweise mehr Zeit
zu haben das wäre ja wirklich
gewinnbringend unter welchen
Voraussetzungen kann das denn alles
passieren also welche Voraussetzungen
muss die Politik schaffen damit dieser
Transformationsprozess wirklich gelingt
ich glaube das wichtigste ist eben vor
allem ein Rahmen für Umschulungen und
Weiterbildungen aufzubauen eben genau
für den Fall dass auf der einen Seite im
Arbeitsmarkt eben Jobs wegfallen auf der
anderen Seite Menschen gesucht werden da
muss man ja eben schauen wie kriege ich
die Beschäftigten von A nach B und dann
wenn es innerhalb des Unternehmens
funktioniert also die Arbeitsplätze an
sich stabil sind dann ist das ein
unternehmensinterne Weiterbildung und
das hatte in der Vergangenheit
eigentlich sehr gut funktioniert
schwieriger wird es in den Fällen wo im
Strukturwandel ein ganzes Unternehmen
verschwindet und sich dann eben die
Frage stellt wie schafft man es diese
Umschulung schon so zu organisieren dass
die Beschäftigten nicht erst durch so
eine Art Tal der Tränen durchgehen
müssen durch eine längere Phase der
Arbeitslosigkeit sondern direkt Fuß
fassen können das ist nicht ganz einfach
auf der anderen Seite die demografische
Entwicklung in Deutschland die spielt
uns was das angeht ganz gut in die
Karten denn wir haben ja nun mal ein
akutes Problem das Fachkräftemangels in
dass wir reinkommen werden das heißt
auch wenn jetzt Jobs wegfallen durch KI
oder dich andere Prozesse haben
diejenigen die das betrifft seine sehr
gute Chance an anderer Stelle auch
wieder Arbeit zu finden und zwar nicht
irgendeine Arbeit sondern auch gut
bezahlt habe Arbeit jetzt ist es ja so
Herr Professor einiges in dem Bereich
geht dann schon schneller als manche das
erwartet hatten wir sehen Chat GPT das
ist also ein Chatbot mit dem man in den
Dialog gehen kann mit dem man übrigens
auch an Moderation schreiben kann die
Fakes und und vieles vieles mehr welche
Gefahren sehen Sie denn
ich sehe tatsächlich weniger gefahren
was den Arbeitsmarkt angeht was jetzt
sage ich mal meine
Spezial Disziplin ist wissenschaftlich
ich sehe eher Gefahren im Bereichen
Desinformationen die Fakes das
irgendwann die KI auch so eingesetzt
werden kann dass man gar nicht mehr
richtig unterscheiden kann ist das noch
die Realität oder ist das eine Fiktion
die ich hier gerade sehe das ist
natürlich eine enorm gefährlicher
Prozess der auch gesteuert und reguliert
werden muss aber der jetzt ja mit dem
Arbeitsmarkt im engeren sind erstmal
nichts zu tun hat Herr Professor eine
ganz kurze Frage noch zum Schluss
Problem ist ja auch dass die KI in den
Händen Weniger Tech Konzern liegt wie
können die Vorteile dieser Technologie
Technologie jetzt gerecht verteilt
werden also was raten sie der
Bundesregierung denn die beraten sie ja
auch
es ist tatsächlich bei KI ein großes
Problem dass die fünf großen Tech
Giganten aus den USA eben sehr sehr
stark das ganze dominieren und ich
glaube da muss eine Regulierung her in
den USA wird sogar schon über die
Zerschlagung dieser Technik diskutiert
das weiß ich nicht da kann auch
Deutschland relativ wenig zu beitragen
aber ich glaube wichtig ist dass in
diesem Geschäftszeiten gerade wo es um
das Information um
diese die Fake Thematik geht dass dort
eben frühzeitig reguliert wird auch klar
gemacht wird in welche Richtung das
gehen kann was auf gar keinen Fall
toleriert wird seitens der Politik und
das ganze möglichst auch wenn es
schwierig ist zu regulieren bevor diese
Welle wirklich ins Rollen kommt Herr
Professor dann vielen herzlichen Dank
gespannt wo die Reise hingeht ich meine
selbstfahrende Autos die perfekt
funktionieren die gibt es auch immer
noch nicht und perfekte
sprachsteuerungssysteme mit
Navigationssystem auch nicht aber das
macht mehr mein Problem sein als das von
jemanden vielen Dank
sehr gerne danke ihm
so blicken wir ins Ausland international
da wächst die Sorge aufgrund der
Situation im Sudan US-Außenminister
blinken fordert gemeinsam mit anderen
darunter auch der
UN-Generalsekretär und der Papst ein
Ende der Gewalt bis jetzt allerdings und
damit beginnen die Nachrichten von
Gundula doch relativ vergeblich muss man
sagen ja die Zahl der Todesopfer im
Sudan steigt dutzende Zivilisten und
dutzende Soldaten sollen getötet
hunderte Menschen verletzt worden sein
die Kämpfe zwischen Armee und einer
paramilitärischen Gruppe dauern an
konzentrieren sich auf das Hauptquartier
der Armee und den staatlichen Rundfunk
schwere Gefechte werden auch aus anderen
Provinzen gemeldet hintergrund ist ein
Machtkampf zwischen zwei generellen de
facto-präsident al-bourhan rechts im
Bild und seinem Stellvertreter der die
Paramilitärs anführt
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder stößt
mit seiner Forderung nach einer Änderung
des Atomgesetzes und einer Übertragung
der Atom Zuständigkeit an die Länder auf
Ablehnung
Bundesumweltministerin lemmt gesagt der
Süddeutschen Zeitung das Grundgesetz
schreibe die Zuständigkeit dem Bund zu
Söder hatte angekündigt alle
landesrechtlichen Möglichkeiten prüfen
zu lassen um so das AKW Isa 2 in Bayern
weiter betreiben zu können die letzten
drei Kernkraftwerke waren gestern gegen
Mitternacht abgeschaltet worden neben
Isar 2 auch der niedersächsische Meiler
Emsland und
Neckarwestheim zwei in Baden-Württemberg
nach Polen und der Slowakei hat auch
Ungarn Getreide Importe aus der Ukraine
vorübergehend verboten damit wollen die
Länder Schaden von der heimischen
Landwirtschaft abwenden große Vorräte
billigen ukrainischen Getreides drückten
die Preise örtlicher Bauern kritik kommt
von der EU die einseitigen Maßnahmen
seien nicht zulässig
Millionen orthodoxer Christen weltweit
haben das Osterfest gefeiert in der
Ukraine erneut überschattet von
russischen Angriffen bei saporicia
zerstörte eine russische Rakete eine
Kirche Kiew meldete zugleich die
Freilassung von 130 Ukrainern in einem
Gefangenenaustausch mit Moskau dort
lobte Präsident Putin die bestärkende
Rolle der Kirche Russland stehe schweren
Herausforderungen gegenüber Patriarch
Kyriel der erste befürwortet die
russische Offensive in der Ukraine
Offensive also viele andere nennen das
Krieg auch am Beispiel Russland sehen
wir Kriege werden leider immer noch
geführt aber die Kriegsführung die hat
sich in Teilen verändert das liegt
natürlich auch an dem Einsatz von
Drohnen bestes Beispiel dafür ist die
Ukraine einige kampfdrohen die dort
eingesetzt werden werden immer
eigenständiger und auch intelligenter
und für Soldaten wird das Töten
abstrakter denn mit dem Joystick in der
Hand erinnert es eher an einen
Computerspiel als an die brutale
Realität wie die Ukraine an Drohnen
ausgebildet werden diesen wirklich sehr
seltenen Einblick hat daran Hass
erhalten
der Ort muss umbenannt bleiben es ist
ein Testgelände für ukrainische
drohnenhersteller und für die Ausbildung
von Soldaten Maxim erklärt die
Funktionsweise der Kampfdrohnen sie
werfen Bomben hinter den feindlichen
Linien ab bei der geplanten
Großoffensive werden auch Drohnen eine
wichtige Rolle spielen
Soldaten Leben sind das Wertvollste was
wir haben und so wussten wir die Ukraine
braucht Roboter und wir bauten einen
Drohnen Prototypen 2016 hatten wir den
ersten erfolgreichen Kampfeinsatz
seitdem entwickeln wir weiter wir wissen
wenn die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen
will dann ist das unser Weg wir brauchen
Drohnen
diese kampfdrohne kann mit ihren Bomben
eine Entfernung von bis zu 45 km
zurücklegen gestartet wird sie von einem
Aluminium Schlitten mit Expandern ein
Staat fast wie bei Segelflugzeugen
leise in Flughöhe nicht zu hören dort
oben wird sie dann von einem Laptop mit
GPS-System ausgesteuert
eine große Gefahr wir wissen das wenn
der Flugkörper auf feindlichem Gebiet
abstürzt kann der Feind jedoch keine
Informationen auslesen unsere Daten und
Software sind in der Bodenstation und
auf höchstem Sicherheitsstandard ich
denke nicht dass jemand das Hacken kann
zumindest nicht unter einem
gerechtfertigten Aufwand da müsste man
schon Bill Gates sein
nur Start und Landung werden manuell per
choice dick gelenkt Flug und Abwurf der
Bombe steuert das Notebook selbst bei
starkem Wind hat die Drohne nur eine
Abweichung von vier Metern die
Zerstörungskraft geht um ein Vielfaches
darüber hinaus die Form des Joysticks
erinnert an Computerspiele das ist auch
so gewollt vor allem junge Soldaten sind
daran gewöhnt
nun müssen leicht sein zuverlässig und
bequem zu steuern sein im Idealfall
agieren sie im Schwarm und im Verbund
mit anderen Waffensystemen entfalten
Drohnen die größte Wirkung sie sind
sicher kein Spielzeug
der Erfolg der geplanten Großoffensive
wird auch davon abhängen wie effizient
russische kommando-stände und
Munitionsdepots zerstört werden können
hinter der Front
Frage nach der moralischen Legitimität
einer Drohne wird immer wieder gestellt
aber ist ein Krieg an sich nicht schon
unmoralisch
bleiben wir mal bei Moral und Anstand
jetzt aber im wirklich politischen
Kontext und der Frage ist aus einer
wirklich engen Männerfreundschaft das
entstanden was wir heute zu spüren
bekommen es geht um die Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von Russland welche über
viele Jahre auf und ausgebaut wurde
nicht nur aber insbesondere durch
Exkanzler Gerhard Schröder ihn oder die
SPD als einzige Sündenböcke hinzustellen
das wäre aber wohl zu einfach über die
Moskau connection und das weggucken
vieler Peter Kunst
ein kalter Russe ein überwältigter
Kanzler war es der große Plan Wladimir
Putins der Gerhard Schröder mit KGB
Geheimdienstmethoden in einem
Männerfreundschaft einwickelte um ihn
dann bei Nord Stream zum bezahlten
Handlanger zu machen der mit seinen
Einflüsterungen dafür sorgte dass
Deutschland alle Vorsicht fahren ließ
und in die gasabhängigkeit von Russland
rutschte
im Nachhinein sieht das vielleicht so
nach dem großen Plan aus man muss sich
zurückversetzen in die Zeit als die
Entscheidung getroffen worden ist den
zusätzlichen Energiebedarf durch ähm
eine weitere Gaspipeline von Russland zu
decken als wir beschlossen hatten ähm
aus der Atomkraft auszusteigen wir
standen vor der Frage was sind dann die
alternativen Kohle wegen CO2 Ausstoß
scheidet aus und dann blieb Gas das
günstige Pipeline Gas aus Russland
Deutschland begann schon in den 1970er
Jahren sich mit dem Erdgas
röhrengeschäft langsam aber sicher an
den russischen Energie Tropf zu hängen
Großverbraucher wie basff investierten
in Nord Stream 1 und 2 das deutsche
Exportmodell baute auf billigströmendes
Erdgas so der Konsens in Politik und
Industrie
obwohl Kanzlerin Merkel Putin früh
misstraute erreichte die
versorgungsabhängigkeit von Russland
unter ihr den Höhepunkt die Regierung
Merkel hat auch nicht reagiert
als Ende der Nullerjahre
zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt Russland schon
einmal versuchte
Gaslieferungen als Instrument zur
Erpressung zu verwenden
da ging es um die Frage ob Gazprom die
vorwärtsintegration in Stadtwerke in
großen Umfang erlaubt würde
Putins Plan mit Gazprom bis in deutscher
Haushalte vorzustoßen er ging auf mit
der europäischen Liberalisierung des
Gasmarktes die eigentlich Monopole
verhindern sollte dafür wurden Erdgas
Handel Leitungsnetze und gasspeicherung
getrennt
aber durch die deutschen Tochterfirmen
von Gazprom Germania fand Russland
überall hinein und konnte Einfluss
ausüben
wie weit die russischen krakenarme
reichten das zeichnet auch ein Buch nach
dass sich mit Deutschlands
Betriebsblindheit in Sachen Russland
beschäftigt rund um die gazpromen
Germania also die deutsche gastformen
Tochter finden wir jede Menge alte SED
und stasi-seilschaften die sich bis in
die schröderzeit durchzieht und der
frühere Stasi Spitzel war nicht vorne
dran steht ja eigentlich kontinuierlich
bis vor kurzem dafür dass da ein
längerer Plan verfolgt wurde Matthias
warnick Ex-Star sie Offizier und
Geschäftsführer erst von Nord Stream 1
und später auch für das Nord Stream
2-projekt Putins gasmänner die sich ihre
Lobbyarbeit für Moskau vergolden ließen
Putin wusste wohl wer mit Gier nicht zu
haben war wen man aber mit politischer
Münze locken konnte wer besonders in den
Reihen der SPD anfällig war für Russland
voll flore als Außenminister setzte
Walter Steinmeier lange auf die
Modernisierungspartnerschaft mit Moskau
als Wirtschaftsminister verkaufte Sigmar
Gabriel auf Wunsch und Drängen von BASF
Deutschlands größten
gas-prom und heute schaut die
Bundesrepublik so in leere pipes
und wir machen jetzt noch mal weiter mit
Nachrichten unter anderem mit Sport aber
nicht mit Fußball der kommt später
zunächst zum Handball die Rhein-Neckar
Löwen aus Mannheim haben zum zweiten Mal
den deutschen handball-pokal gewonnen
großer Jubel nach einem dramatischen
Endspiel gegen den deutschen Meister SC
Magdeburg auch nach der Verlängerung
stand es unentschieden der Sieg für die
Löwen kam im 7 Meter werfen
in der Fußball-Bundesliga haben sich VfL
Wolfsburg und der Tabellen sechste Bayer
Leverkusen torlos getrennt ebenfalls
Unentschieden gegen die Partie zwischen
dem Tabellen dritten Union Berlin und
VfL Bochum zu Ende 1:1 und Werder Bremen
verlor gegen den SC Freiburg 1 zu 2 die
Breisgauer damit auf Platz 5 der Tabelle
der Tabellen letzte Hertha BSC hat sich
von Trainer Sandro schwarz getrennt
ausschlaggebend war die zwei zu fünf
Niederlage am Freitagabend beim
bisherigen Schlusslicht Schalke 04
Nachfolge wird härter Urgestein pald der
47-Jährige war bereits zweimal Chefcoach
der Hertha Hauptaufgabe nun der
Klassenerhalt
[Applaus]
für seine umstrittenen Äußerungen in
konzerninternen Mitteilungen hat
Matthias Döpfner der Chef der Axel
Springer Verlagsgruppe um Entschuldigung
gebeten er habe mit seinen Worten viele
gekränkt verunsichert oder verletzt
sagte er auf der Website der
Bild-Zeitung Döpfner hatte sich wie die
Zeit berichtete in E-Mails und
Chatnachrichten zum Beispiel abfällig
über ostdeutsche geäußert auf dem
Gelände des ehemaligen KZ Buchenwald
wurde mit einer Gedenkfeier an die Opfer
der Nationalsozialisten erinnert Anlass
die Befreiung des Konzentrationslagers
vor 78 Jahren im Mittelpunkt des
diesjährigen Gedenkens die Verfolgung
der Sinti und Roma und 3.500 Angehörige
der Minderheit waren nach Buchenwald
verschleppt worden Thüringens
Ministerpräsident ramelomante es sei
wichtig zu erinnern und die Geschichte
weiter aufzuarbeiten
stimmt aus der Geschichte lernen und
erinnern so wichtig daran schließt auch
unser Ausblick an
[Musik]
es ist der Ort an dem Willy Brandt einst
niederkniete und um Vergebung Bad für
etwas das schwerlich vergeben werden
kann das Denkmal der Helden des
warschauerghettos erinnert an den
Aufstand gegen die deutschen Besatzer
vor 80 Jahren hier wird am Mittwoch der
Bundespräsident während der Gedenkfeier
eine Rede halten der erste deutsche
Staatsgast die man das gestattet eine
große Geste Polens
kann Deutschland noch bauen diese Frage
stellt nächste Woche der 14
wohnungsbautag aus Sicht der Verbände
nein von 400.000 Wohnungen die die Ampel
pro Jahr bauen wollte schaffte sie mit
Mühe die Hälfte was die Regierung dazu
sagt und welche Lösungen sie anbietet
Antworten am Donnerstag wird Christian
Lindner als Parteichef bestätigt der
Bundesparteitag der FDP in Berlin
entscheidet unter anderem darüber der
Chef ist unter Druck schlechte Umfragen
verlorene Landtagswahlen Kompromisse in
der Ampel denkt Zettel oder doch
geschlossene rein alles ist möglich am
Freitag
und morgen Abend wird die frühere
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel trotz
aller kritischer Würdigung auch aus
ihrer Partei der CDU mit der
höchstmöglichen Auszeichnung der
Bundesrepublik geehrt das Großkreuz in
besonderer Ausführung das wurde bisher
nur zweimal verliehen an Konrad Adenauer
und Helmut Kohl das Wetter in dieser
neuen Woche bleibt durch wachsen
zweigeteilt der Norden bekommt mehr
Sonne ab so bleibt es morgen im
Nordwesten trocken und dort zeigt sich
die Sonne länger im Süden und Südosten
regnet es leicht 8 bis 16 Grad auch in
den nächsten Tagen scheint die Sonne im
Norden am längsten im Süden gibt es mehr
Wolken und es fällt auch noch etwas
Regen mit 9 bis 17 Grad ändern sich die
Temperaturen kaum
das war's von uns beiden nächste Woche
sind dann hier wieder Marietta und Heinz
am Start und haben dann das Geschehen
für Sie im Blicke für den Restabend
übernehmen dass die Kollegen aus der
heute Redaktion Christina von Ungarn
Sternberg meldet sich um 0:30 Uhr machen
sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]